yeah I mean there's always this cycle of
sort of boom and bust I think because
the at least just speaking of the
internet market the the most recent boom
which is still going on as far as i can
tell has not been nearly as insane as
the first boom i don't think we'll have
anything like that again it's much more
of an we're in an industry that's
getting much closer to a more normal
business cycle type of thing where
things are up things are down and you
sort of bubble along through it as
opposed to this really fairly
astonishing / valuations that were going
on and then the fairly astonishing under
valuations that were going on I mean it
was a bloodbath beyond all belief and I
don't think we'll see that again I think
we've got you know businesses that are
that are turning profits we've got
businesses that are on their way to
profitability we have business models
that people understand so that we kind
of have an idea of what can be sustained
and what can't so you know in this round
we haven't seen you know billions dollar
investments in delivering groceries to
people's houses and things like that
which just never worked out in the old
one right so yeah I mean yeah I think
it'd be fine to have a little shake out
and sort of you know yeah clean up those
extraneous web videos I'm not sure what
that means I don't know how those sites
are doing I was I remember hearing just
I don't know randomly hearing before
YouTube was bought that they were
spending a million dollars a month on
bandwidth and they had no idea how they
were going to monetize her a business
model and I just said well they're going
to flame out really quick well I was
wrong you know they got bought for one
and a half billion or whatever but even
now you know if you look at I have no
idea what their bandwidth bill would be
today but the thing is is when you look
at a company like like Google let's say
they spend two million a month on
bandwidth and they're not monetizing it
they can afford it right that's a 24
million dollar a year investment in a
major brand they can just subsidize it
they can just carry it forever is as
sort of part of the the Google brand and
just
the image why not I think it probably
cost a little more than that to keep
YouTube going but it does pose a problem
though for a lot of the smaller sites
they may not have that luxury of saying
oh we can just lose money forever
because we're just part of a brand image